here's a deacon what guests have to say
after the show okay we're back on the
Internet
dr. Wes will the prison hunger strikes
across California have their intended
effect of limiting long-term solitary
confinement is that the issue that
they're striking events with the
long-term solitary confinement which is
the fall tour Charlie not only that but
you know they were promised two years
ago that they would there would be
certain kinds of promises follow through
on because there was a strike two years
ago so I think this is very important
it's highly significant and the
beautiful thing about it is it's
prisoners of all colors coming together
so you got some of the gangsters in the
brown in the white in the red in the
black all together that's hard to do in
prison because prison is there to do
anyway it's hard I know but prison
not that I know except for watching you
got a glad experience here I've watched
oz but it's very tribal and you gotta
let it aside you can't get into MSNBC
lockup that's right I mean oh yeah
actually the prison on MSNBC doesn't
look that bad when I watch that show I'm
like prison that's okay the Republican
Party is supposedly this is for you Matt
not about big government but ultimately
isn't that isn't that all that's left in
the farm bill oh the farm bill this week
lanessa saw that [ __ ] they hold it for
everything except the food stamps for
the poor yeah yeah yeah well let me I'll
start but I know you've got something
that's um look I think it was smart when
they initially split the bill right so
they had food stamps and uh and the farm
bill together and it doesn't it make
sense for a political coalition but the
two things don't necessarily go together
and I had hoped that what they would do
is actually cut some of the fat out of
the farm bill and some of the giveaways
to the big farmers and maybe cut some of
the fat out of the food stamps but keep
it going make it more efficient but
instead it looks like Republicans have
chosen to reward their chosen group of
people and I think that that's
unfortunate yeah I think the whole thing
is an abomination and it's disgusting
and if I were in Congress I absolutely
wouldn't have voted for it I think it's
complete fork
and the whole thing should have been
voted down it's awful work for pork Mike
as an Eagle Scout how do you feel about
the Boy Scout of America's new policy on
gay Boy Scouts and their exclusion of
gay adult leaders I guess you can be gay
if you're the Scout but not the leader
who asked me that question uh Dunbar
Sheree select 69 someone you know yeah
awesome no a lot of what a super
question I appreciate that
well it's great first of all it's a
distinguished Eagle Scout but let's not
split hairs
oh come well you know what San Francisco
don't you I live in San Francisco I got
around to the Opera I'm single and yet
and yet you got your start in the Opera
yeah I did actually
long time ago uh and reading books like
the one you were reading earlier how
loud real slow and low and stuff like
that you know uh I started as a
ballerina we may have dated um I'm I'm
glad I'm glad it's behind them as it
were so does mine if you will now you
know what the Boy Scouts are a big fat
easy target and they have been for a
long time but the truth is they they
really changed my life as a kid I mean I
went in shy backward stuttering and I
came out different and I'm grateful for
it to this day I work with the scouts I
work with the Future Farmers of America
and SkillsUSA which I think are the
three youth organizations that still
really matter I I personally think the
country needs those organizations and my
sympathies are with the kids in every
case the leadership I don't I don't have
a real connection to I'm glad they
worked it out but this thing it's been
it's been toxic for recruitment I get
that it's an important issue but so
often when people talk about it it's
it's to the exclusion of the kids who
are in it right you got a million kids
and it matters and they're listening and
look I'm glad they're engaged I'm glad
it's resolved so that's a long way of
saying yes
or - no yeah I was gonna say yes or no
should they have a merit badge for
wedding planning just answer that what
are your thoughts I guess this is for
anybody on Elizabeth Warren's bill to
tie federal student loans but federal
student loan interest rates to the same
rates the biggest banks are getting at
the Fed that's Elizabeth Warren no the
big one he's the real deal right and not
a good idea
the wanted banks really be getting a
better rape and student loans working
students of welcome no absolutely come
on do you have to just be on the wrong
side reflexively yes can't you be on the
right side we're on the right side but
it can't be popular that's our rule I
cannot be popular but what why is this a
bad thing Liz I don't know that I don't
know that it's politically politically I
will just say I mean as a political
consultant it's very possible that this
is actually going to be very effective
for her is a policy that she is putting
out there now to slightly drift off
topic I would just like to say that
since we're talking about Elizabeth
Warren and since there's a lot of
speculation going on about 2016
everybody keeps talking about Hillary
Clinton now I don't agree with Elizabeth
Warren as a matter of policy I know
everybody's really shocked by that right
but I would um I would actually be
interested to see if Elizabeth Warren
would like to have a shot at 2016 I
think she could actually be a more
interesting and more compelling pan and
she'd be our first liberal Native
American and Hillary president I believe
I'd like that's possibly true if that's
possible yeah much more of a real
fighter for left causes I'll early is to
me much more of a hawk much more of a
centrist much more of a corporatist
mother certainly certainly I'm a hawk
and right yeah I think that's right
oh no and I'm with you let's let's draft
I think I think there's always a lot do
it together I think there's always a lot
of talk about
to have more women in politics and I
agree with that so let's stop with all
of that it must be Hillary and let's
actually diversify and start taking a
look at other qualified but what about
men
men can run too and can run too now I
can't we have a man in there for what
we're done we're done with you
we're done we're done with the show
actually we're out of time thank you
very much you're a terrific ride Real
Time with Bill Maher Friday night at
10:00 ask bill and his guests to her
questions right after the show at
hbo.com